the two-year-old boy that was killed in
an alligator attack at disney world will
be buried today in Nebraska Lane Graves
was grabbed and killed by the predator
in a lagoon at one of the resorts hotels
divers found his body after a 16-hour
search and now there are growing
questions about how much Disney could be
held responsible for this terrible
attack CBS News legal expert Ricky
Clayman is here at the table to discuss
Ricky good morning good morning this
remains one of the worst stories that
most people have ever heard I can't
imagine how horrible it was for the
parents what could Disney's possible
defense be here well Disney is going to
say if they were to have a defense of it
the case where to go forward in that
manner dizzy is going to say look it
wasn't foreseeable that we've never had
an alligator attack on a human being and
that killed anyone period that there
hasn't been an alligator attack at all
where there's even an injury in 45 years
therefore it wasn't foreseeable that
also say that there were no swimming
signs that were posted and that when
people go and flout a no swimming sign
that they assume the risk the third
thing they're going to say is that
everybody knows that there are
alligators in Central Florida and to
that last I say for people like me who
grew up in the Midwest and live in the
concrete city of New York I don't expect
a gator to be on the property at Walt
Disney World now you know how it is
different Ricky then note beware of
alligators is it not well I think no
swimming is highly different that be
very alligators so we have to look at
what the plaintiff has to prove if it
were to go to trial plaintiff has to
simply say that they knew does he knew
prove it up that they had knowledge what
did they know when did they know it and
they had a duty to warn they didn't warn
why would Disney ever want this to go to
you don't ever want to argue with the
family of a top use bananas on your
property you got a million dollars it
yeah I know I say if I'm advising Disney
that my best advice is not only write
the check and write it big but write it
before complaint right and
oh wow and what has huge plan about it
should have already happen again I think
it should bar had been written and it
should have been written with a sense of
we are so very very sorry I I these are
all the changes were making how can we
make it up there is no question that
that can never replace your size what
can we do of course his men and I am
sure and that they have done well with
making the family feel as best that
Disney can under the circumstances other
changes already though they are very
rewarding whatever you guys manage yeah
they what they have done which would
show to the public that they could have
done it but that is not admissible in
court should go to court yeah this
stress I think Nora nobody in yesterday
what no guys are saying here right tell
me said I was just there with my three
kids on that very beef but you always an
interesting point why would this
possibly go to court they're very smart
people indecent yeah right i would hope
so they are yeah i don't believe it ray
can always act is now always great to
have you here Ricky thank you